[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est pas mal non
parce que c'est des mères et pas des
mœurs ça là c'est comme le mec qui a tué
son père et qui a couché avec sa mère
c'est un œdème
œdipe ce mot là il y a qu'un seul s
alors pourquoi tu dis ah bah surdi tout
le temps à base ce mot là
est-ce que tu dis exécutif ou exécutif
bah là c'est pareil exécrable du coup
14 peut-être quoi un 15e
[Musique]
désolé j'aurais jamais dû t'appeler
comme ça je t'appellerai pas comme ça tu
m'as appelé comment je t'ai appelé mon
mari d'amour est-ce que tu peux venir me
faire un bisou tout simplement
voilà je mérite pas d'eau quand même je
mérite pas de t'appeler comme tu m'as
appelé je t'appellerai plus jamais comme
ça je suis désolé
j'hésite fort parce que je sais que si
je le fais vraiment et ben
t'inquiète pas
on est sur le point de découvrir le
costard que Liam a ramené pour ce soir
mais avant je pouvais quand même qu'on
débrief les messages qu'on a reçu de la
semaine passée parce que visiblement
vous allez pas accroché de ouf donc
c'était marron
ouais orange quoi Frédéric je sais pas
qui lui a fourni le costume à Camille
Combal c'était pas une grosse merveille
télévisuelle
Camille Combal est-ce que tu empoisonné
le chien de ta styliste c'est quoi ces
costumes dans base ça a l'air d'une
fonction
c'est mon Camille Combal a pris son
costume dans l'armoire 70 non c'est dans
l'armoire de Lia qui vit qui vit dans
les années 70